THIS IS ANOTHER PRO- WORKER
FAMILY PRO- COMMUNITY THIS
WEEKEND ESPECIALLY POLYMERIC.
THESE TWO MEN ANDREW CARNEGIE
AND ROCKEFELLER LIED AND SHE’D
JUST CHEATED FOR THE PURSUIT
OF ECONOMIC POWER THE ROBBER
BARON OF CAPITALISM IN A
HEATED THAT SO THEY SET ABOUT
CHANGING THEIR IMAGE OF WANTED
PEOPLE TO FORGET ABOUT ALL THE
TERRIBLE THINGS THEY DID SO
CARNEGIE BELT LIBRARIES AND
ROCKEFELLER SET UP A
FOUNDATIONS TO CON THE
ESTABLISHMENT INTO MOVING ON
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE SEEING
TODAY WITH THESE TWO.
BUSH AND BIDEN TO FORGET ABOUT
WHAT THEY DID THEY ARE
DESPERATE FOR PRAISE AND PATS
ON THE BACK FROM THE
ESTABLISHMENT BUT UNLIKE THE
ORIGINAL ROBBER BARONS WHO DID
SOME GOOD WITH THEIR
DEFLECTION TACTICS WITH BUSH
AND BIDEN IT IS ENTIRELY
NEGATIVE IN THE PAST FEW DAYS
THEY HAVE CYNICALLY COME TO
GATHER TO PACK ON -- ATTACK A
COMMON ENEMY, GEORGE W. BUSH
USE THE ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11 TO
IMPLY THAT REPUBLICANS THE
PEOPLE WHO PUT HIM IN THE OVAL
OFFICE ARE LIKE THE 9/11
TERRORIST ALTHOUGH HE DIDN’T
JUST MEAN THOSE WHO COMMITTED
CRIMES HE KNEW PERFECTLY WELL
HOW HIS REMARKS WOULD BE
AMPLIFIED HE INTENDED TO SMEAR
THE REPUBLICAN BASE BUT A SICK
CYNICAL TRANSPARENT PLOY TO
INGRATIATE HIMSELF WITH THE
POLITICAL ESTABLISHMENT DOES
HE REALLY THINK HE WILL MAKE
AMERICANS FORGET WHAT HE DID?
INSTEAD IT HAS DONE THE EXACT
OPPOSITE AT TIMES US TO
REMEMBER THAT GEORGE W. BUSH
LET OSAMA BIN LADEN SLIP
THROUGH HIS FINGERS
DECEMBER 2001 BECAUSE HE WAS
TOO BUSY DIALING UP PLANS FOR
THE INVASION OF IRAQ.
WE REMEMBER BUSH TOOK US TO
WAR ON A LIE AND ACCORDING TO
THOSE AROUND AT THE TIME HE
DID IT JUST TO LOOK TOUGHER
THAN HIS FATHER THE ACTUAL WAR
HERO.
WE REMEMBER THE BUSHES WAR OF
VANITY SQUANDERED THE SYMPATHY
AND UNITY OF THE CIVILIZED
WORLD OF 9/11 THE MATTER HOW
MANY PORTRAITS HE PAINTS OR
SPEECHES HE MAKES SUCKING UP
WE WILL NEVER FORGET THAT
GEORGE W. BUSH AFFECT MILLIONS
NEEDLESSLY TO DESTABILIZE THE
MIDDLE EAST ENDLESSLY INTO
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF YOUR
MONEY CORRUPTLY TO PUT IN THE
POCKETS OF HIS CRONIES LED BY
THE CHENEY’S WHOSE FAMILY
BUSINESS IS WAR BY OTHER
PEOPLE AND THEIR CHILDREN.
BIDEN SAID HE WANTED TO END
THE WAR NOT JUST OVERSEAS BUT
HERE AT HOME.
>> WE MUST END THIS UNCIVIL
WAR.
CONSERVATIVE VERSUS LIBERAL.
URBAN VERSUS RURAL.
STEVE: JUST HAS HIS ABJECT
SURRENDER TO THE TALIBAN DID
NOT STOP AND RESTART THE
ENDLESS WAR IN AFGHANISTAN
ENDING OUT THE UNCIVIL WAR BUT
REVIVING IT THAT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
FOR THE SECURITY CRISIS AND A
CRIME CRISIS AND INFLATION
CRISIS AND TO BRING THE
COUNTRY TO GATHER IN EVERY
SINGLE THING HE SAID OR DOES
TRIBES IS FURTHER APART.
AS A CENTRIST NOW THE FRONT
MAN FOR THE EXTREME FAR LEFT
GOVERNMENT IN HISTORY BIDEN
THINKS MEAL FORGET HE CAN
BARELY STRING TWO SENTENCES
TOGETHER BUT EVEN IN THE
MOMENT HE TRIES TO DISTRACT US
FROM HIS FAILURES AND HIS
LIES.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE TO PROTECT
VACCINATED WORKERS FROM AN
VACCINATED COWORKERS.
IT IS CALLED A VACCINE.
JUST STOPPED FOR A SECOND AND
DESCRIBE ACCURATELY WHAT WE
SAW ON THURSDAY.
IN OUR PRESIDENT WHO WENT OFF
SCRIPT TO DIRECTLY CONTRADICT
SCIENCE OR IT WAS IN THE
SCRIPT AND HE SUCCESSFULLY
READ THAT OUT IN WHICH CASE WE
HAVE A RETIRED WHITE HOUSE
OPERATION HAS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYING
THINGS THIS IS NOT A JOKE
FOLKS THIS IS A CRISIS OF
GOVERNMENT.
AND BIDEN REMINDS US WHY WE
MUST NOT MOVE ON AND OF COURSE
MORE THAN ANYTHING THAT
APPLIES TO HIS GREATEST
CATASTROPHE THE NARCISSISTIC
TO STOP THE ENDLESS WAR AT ANY
COST WHETHER DEAD MARINES IN
AFGHANISTAN OR ANOTHER 9/11 OR
AMERICANS AND OUR ALLIES
DESPERATE AND FEARING FOR
THEIR LIVES IN THE HANDS OF
THOSE THAT ATTACKED US 20
YEARS AGO WHAT A GROTESQUE WAY
TO COMMEMORATE THE BRAVERY AND
HEROISM AND SACRIFICE OF SOME
THE AMERICANS NOT JUST ON THAT
DAY BUT THE TWO DECADES
SINCE.
BIDEN SURRENDERING TO THE
TALIBAN LEAVING PEOPLE BEHIND
AND EQUIPMENT BEHIND AND OUR
MORALITY.
THE APPALLING REGIME STILL
CAN’T SEEM TO COMPREHEND THE
GRAVITY OF WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
LISTEN TO THIS FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WHEN CHALLENGE NOT
LETTING PLANES TAKE OFF.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL OFFICIAL
STATEMENT.
WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
MANY PEOPLE ARE FEELING AS A
TRY TO FACILITATE FURTHER
CHARTER AND OTHER PASSAGE OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN HOWEVER WE DO
NOT HAVE AIR ASSETS WE DO NOT
CONTROL THE AIRSPACE.
EXACTLY.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT HE RAN
AWAY.
AND TALK ABOUT IT AS IT IS THE
IMMUTABLE FACT OF LIFE YOU
TOOK THE AIR ASSETS OUT OF THE
COUNTRY YOU DID THIS AND NOW
YOU TURN AROUND AND WRING YOUR
HANDS?
YOU REALLY ARE THE LOWEST OF
THE LOW ACTUALLY THERE WAS A
LOWER POINT.
WHAT WAS THE WORD THE WHITE
HOUSE USED TO DESCRIBE THE
MURDERERS PROFESSIONAL AND
DESPICABLE JUST LIKE THE DRONE
STRIKE WAG THE DOG WE ARE
LEARNING.
THEY MISTOOK WATER CANISTERS
FOR BOMBS KILLING AN AID
WORKER AND NINE OTHER
CIVILIANS AND THIS IS A GREAT
OVER THE HORIZON ANTI- TERROR
STRATEGY IT SAYS OVER THE
HORIZON IS SOMEWHERE OVER THE
RAINBOW GOT HELP US IF THEY
ARE LOOKING AT BOMBS AND THINK
THEIR WATER CANISTERS.
AND THEN HAVE THE NERVE TO
SUGGEST ALL THIS STRENGTHENS
AMERICA TO FREEZE IS UP TO
CONCENTRATE ON THE REAL THREAT
FROM CHINA THEY ARE RIGHT
ABOUT THE THREAT THAT THE IDEA
THAT THIS BIDEN REGIME TO EVER
STAND UP TO CHINA IS THE
READOUT FROM THE PHONE CALL
THIS IS AN ACTUAL QUOTE FROM
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL HE SOUGHT
TO EXPLAIN ACTIONS TOWARD
CHINA THAT IN THE WAY IT IS
NOT MISINTERPRETED AS TO SORT
IT OUT THAT IS THE BIDEN
STRATEGY ON THE THREAT THE
WHOLE AFGHAN DISASTER WOULD
ENABLE HIM TO PROTECT US FROM
NOT TO UNDERMINE BEIJING.
NO WONDER THERE WERE REPORTS
CHINA IS TAKING OVER BAGRAM
WITH THE STRATEGIC ASSETS THAT
BITING GAVE UP OVERNIGHT.
NOTHING BETTER CORRUPT MACHINE
POLITICIAN WITH NO PRINCIPLES
OR INTEGRITY OR DECENCY.
HE SAID HE WOULD BRING
COMPASSION BUT INSTEAD GAVE US
CRUELTY PROMISED CONFIDENCE
BUT DELIVERED CHAOS ELECTED AS
A MODERATE CENTRIST THAT WAS
SWORN IN WITH THE FAR LEFT
SOCIALIST TAKEOVER RUNNING
AROUND YESTERDAY WITH THE
BIDEN SIGNS HE SAW.
HONESTLY CONSIDERING THE
DAMAGE HE HAS DONE TO THIS